a kid-friendly competitive multiplayer
shooter was a strange concept when
nintendo introduced the very first
splatoon the unique zone control
mechanics made combat important but
somewhat incidental to the chief goal of
covering everything in sticky goop
painting the battlefield gave an
immediate and intuitive visual sense of
who's winning and losing without the
need for a clunky scoreboard that
elegant design was the kind of
delightful surprise that nintendo's
become known for
after two games in a major expansion
splatoon 3 serves as a refinement and
compilation of everything that came
before it it's less novel this time
around but it's still a delight and it
all comes together as the most robust
platoon game yet
[Music]
splatoon 3 assumes that you don't know
all of this of course starting you off
with a short tutorial that teaches you
the basics of splatting before dumping
you into the main hub area a new city
called splatsville and the heart of the
desert splatlands from there you're
encouraged to explore to learn more
about all of the gameplay options and
sights to visit which is a little
overwhelming at first the city isn't
terribly large it is mostly a hub for
other game modes but it feels dense with
activity and nooks to explore you can
jump into the single player campaign
co-op salmon run or competitive
multiplayer as you please
the single player serves as the best
starting point for new players since it
gives you more opportunity to hone your
splatting skills than the brief
pre-splatsville introduction it's much
more than a glorified tutorial though
the campaign is lengthy and makes
excellent use of the mechanics to
iterate and present new types of
challenges the story follows your
created character as the newest recruit
in a team of special agents as they
explore the island of alterna which is
said to hold secrets to understanding
this post-apocalyptic squid world there
are some references to previous events
and characters but for the most part the
tale stands on its own and true to its
promise it actually does explain what
happened to humanity splatoon fans who
have been itching to know why the world
is now occupied by hybrid squids and
octopuses will be pleased to finally get
some answers the major threat in the
story though has less to do with
humanity itself and more to do with
learning what's up with a giant
conspicuous rocket covered in fuzzy ooze
progress through the campaign is
achieved by exploring challenge stages
but to reach them you need to navigate
around or through the fuzzy use falling
in will turn you into a captain
caveman-like creature and result in
instant death gathering your winnings in
the stages can be cashed into pop
pulsating ooze bubbles which causes a
chain reaction to erase some of the fuzz
and open new paths it's all nicely
elegant and the system is flexible
enough to let you opt out of a stage if
it's giving you trouble and just find
another the stage design itself shows a
tremendous amount of creativity through
the sheer variety of different kinds of
challenges the game ventures into bare
knuckle platforming combat scenarios and
even light puzzle solving all without
feeling foreign to its core paint gun
mechanic the one drawback is the enemy
design which does not have enough
variety to sustain itself over an 8-10
hour campaign you'll find yourself
facing off against the same handful of
enemy types with some minor variation
over and over
despite that the finale feels like an
appropriately monumental conclusion not
just to this game but to the trilogy as
a whole splatoon 3 amps up the scale of
the final encounter to such absurd
proportions that i couldn't help but
laugh it's also a test of skill unlike
anything else in the campaign which
makes it feel both thrilling and also
maybe a little bit cheap given the
sudden spike in difficulty the city
itself which is the hub for the story
mode and the wealth of multiplayer
options can feel overwhelming there's a
handy shortcut feature in the menu to
jump straight into whatever area you
want but it's also enjoyable to just
walk around the city discovering where
everything is it makes the city feel
lived in and complete in a way that a
simple menu might not even if it's a bit
extraneous sometimes the frame rate
seemed to drop slightly while i was
exploring though so my switch oled
hardware might be having trouble keeping
up with the demands of a bustling city
[Music]
the traditional competitive mode turf
war is as frenetic as ever pitting two
dueling teams against each other for
control of a single arena the new stages
that rotated in during pre-release
multiplayer sessions fit right into the
splatoon milieu with slightly more
emphasis on verticality in spots to make
use of the new squid surge maneuver
splatoon has always made great use of
cover without exactly being a cover
shooter because getting the drop on
opponents behind a corner is so key to
success and the new maps are bursting
with hidden alcoves and shortcuts that
reward exploring to that end splatoon 3
feels like it has thought through its
place as a serious competitive game
giving top tier players more tools to
hone their craft the recon mode is
easier to find if you want to learn the
ins and outs of a map before jumping in
to play competitively the new lobby
system where you wait between matches
lets you tinker with weapons and see
their damage outputs on dummies which
may be helpful for less experienced
players to find the one that feels right
the co-op salmon run makes its return as
well now letting you play any time you
like instead of only during
pre-scheduled events as someone who
prefers co-op multiplayer to competitive
this is a real highlight for me salmon
run is essentially a horde mode having
you take down encroaching waves of angry
fish and collecting eggs to advance to
the next phase of combat it can get
chaotic as you ratchet up the difficulty
but i haven't had enough time yet to
determine if the mode ends up feeling
too repetitive when i can play as much
as i want and that's indicative of my
overall experience with the multiplayer
as well nintendo held some pre-release
sessions for reviewers to put the game
through its paces but that handful of
sessions wasn't enough time and didn't
take place in a live multiplayer
environment i also haven't yet had the
opportunity to try the new card based
minigame table turf battle though i did
find a few packs littered around the
single player campaign and i'd like to
give the new tri-color splat-fests and
higher rank anarchy battles they're due
as well it'll take more time
post-release to give these aspects the
serious evaluation they deserve i'll be
continuing to play once splatoon 3 goes
live to four more finalized fonts
as it stands splatoon 3 is a wildly
inventive story campaign paired with a
massive amount of multiplayer modes and
options making it the most robust
splatoon game so far i need more time to
put the multiplayer modes through their
paces but the foundation appears strong